The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: All right.
And I really wanted to show
you my little hook video
and I downloaded it so I
thought we'd start just
by watching that and then I'll
pick up about modeling phones.
So this takes like
nine or 10 minutes,
but I just thought it was cute.
And I made it and I
want you to see it.
So let's do that to start.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
We're here at the Harvard
University Botany Library,
looking at a first edition of
Robert Hooke's Micrographia,
published--
How do I get rid
of the bar, Greg?
Oh, there it is.
show the microscopic
structure of materials.
And it has a number of
remarkable drawings in it.
Here we see drawings of silk.
These are two different silks.
On the top here, we
have a fine-waled silk.
And in this more details
drawing down here,
you can see the patterned
weaving of the silk.
The bottom image here is
a drawing of watered silk.
And over here, there's another
higher magnification image.
And you can see the pattern
here is more sharply angled.
And it appears that
this sharper angle here
gives the different texture to
the surface finish of the silk.
So here we see a
drawing of charred wood.
And one of the things I find
interesting about this drawing
is how similar it is to modern
electron micrographs which
we've seen before.
And in this drawing, we can
see two of the main features.
We see these small cells,
which are fibers that provide
structural support to the tree.
And we see these
larger cells here,
which are vessels
which allow fluids
to go up and down the tree.
And here we see a drawing of
the surface of a rosemary leaf,
with the unexpected,
tiny, little bars.
And this is something
that you can only
see with the microscope.
You wouldn't expect to
see those when you just
feel the surface of
the rosemary leaf.
So it's kind of interesting
that with the microscope,
you can see these features that
are invisible to the naked eye.
One of the main themes
of material science
is that the property
of materials
are related to their structure.
And so being able
to see the structure
at a microscopic
scale is very helpful.
And today, we can even see the
structure at the atomic scale.
Robert Hooke
understood this idea.
And in the description
of the cork,
Hooke states, "I
no sooner discerned
these-- which were the first
microscopical pores I ever
saw-- but methought that I had
with the discovery of them,
perfectly hinted to me the true
and intelligible reason for all
of the phenomena of cork."
So what he's saying here is
that by looking at the structure
and looking at the cells
here in the drawing,
he thinks he can understand
the properties of cork
or the phenomena of cork.
What was it about
Robert Hooke that
allowed him to make this book?
Why was it him and
not somebody else?
Well, Robert Hooke had kind
of an interesting history.
He grew up on the Isle of Wight.
And as a boy, he
loved making drawings.
And he got quite skilled
at making drawings.
The other thing was, he loved
making models of things.
He made models of ships.
He made a wooden clock
that was a working
clock when he was a kid.
And as a teenager,
he moved to London.
And he became an apprentice
to Sir Peter Lilley,
who was a famous
painter of the time.
So his drawing was good enough
that he would be working
with a very well-known painter.
After he did that, he went
to the Westminister School.
And he studied classics.
He studied mathematics.
But he also learned
to use a lathe.
And this was also very
helpful in him making
various sorts of apparatus.
And as a student at
Oxford, he worked
in the lab of Robert Boyle.
And his job in that lab was to
develop scientific apparatus.
And he did things
like he built pumps
that allowed Robert Boyle
to do the experiments that
led to Boyle's Law.
When he returned to
London after Oxford,
he became the Curator
of Experiments
at the Royal Society.
And one of the things he
did was he got a microscope.
He improved that microscope,
increasing their magnification,
which was what allowed him to
make the beautiful drawings
that we see today.
And here in the
preface of the book,
we see that he even made a
drawing of his microscope.
So this thing down here-- this
is Robert Hooke's microscope.
The development
of new microscopes
with higher and
higher magnifications
continues to this day.
Scanning electron microscopes
were invented in the 1960s.
And today, we have transmission
electron microscopes
and atomic force
microscopes with even higher
magnifications.
At these higher
magnifications, we
can see details that Hooke
was unable to see because
of the limitations
of the microscope
that he had-- the
optical microscope.
But it's interesting
to see today
the images we see in
a scanning electron
microscope at a similar
magnification to those
that Hooke saw in his
optical microscope.
And it's remarkable to see
how many of the features
that we see in these much
more fancy microscopes
that he was able to
capture in his drawings
with his simple
optical microscope.
So here we have a
picture of cork.
We have Hooke's drawings showing
two perpendicular planes.
We also have this nice, little
drawing of a cork branch here.
Cork is the bark from
the cork oak tree.
And in Hooke's drawings
of the microstructure,
we can see these cells
here are roughly box-like.
They're more or
less rectangular.
And these cells here look
more or less circular.
So there's these two
different perpendicular
planes in the cork.
And when we look at these
scanning electron micrographs,
we can see very
similar structure.
There are some cells
that are roughly boxlike,
and others that are more or less
hexagonal or roughly rounded.
One feature that Hooke was
not able to see, though,
that you do see on the
scanning electron micrographs,
is the waviness
in the cell walls.
And that was because the
resolution of his microscope
was insufficient to see
that level of detail.
And here in this
illustration on the bottom
here is a drawing of sponge.
And when we look at the
scanning electron micrograph,
we see that the structure is
remarkably similar to what
Hooke has drawn.
So here we have Hooke's
drawing of feathers.
And we can see he's made several
drawings at different length
scales.
And if we look at this one
here, we see the barbule.
And you can see these
little hooked regions there.
And those hooks lock
into the little feathers
over on this side over here
of the adjacent barbule.
And in the higher
magnification picture,
you can see on one barbule,
there's hooks on one side
but not on the other.
And it's this hooking of
the two sections together
that allows the
feathers to maintain
a smooth surface for the
wing when the bird is flying.
And you can see the
same sort of thing
when you look at the
electron micrograph.
So you can see the little hooks
on one side of the barbules.
And you can see how they
interconnect together
with the next barb.
One of the most reproduced
images from Hooke's book
is that of the flea--
this image we see here.
And you can see why.
It's a gorgeous image.
And it shows details that
people had never seen before.
People were amazed to see that
the little flea that they might
have found on their
dog or something
was actually made up
of this compound body,
with all these little plates
and little hairs here.
And you can see these little
tiny claws on the legs,
and the legs have
all these hairs.
Nobody had any idea that
this is what a flea actually
looked like.
And so it was an
amazing drawing.
And it was something that
people were just stunned by when
Hooke's book came out.
And if we look at a modern
electron micrograph,
we can see it's
remarkably similar if we
look at the same magnification.
So Hooke showed many
of the same details,
showed some of the
same hairs on the legs,
showed the same sorts of
plates, showed the claws
at the ends of the legs.
And our modern image is probably
from a different species
of flea.
We don't know what
species of flea
that Hooke actually looked at.
But you can see there's
a tremendous similarity
between the two images.
And it's remarkable how
many of the features
that Hooke was able to
capture in his drawing.
And here we have the
compound eye of the fly.
And this, again, was astonishing
to people in Hooke's day.
And even today, people
look at this image,
and they're pretty amazed at
the detail in this drawing.
And again, we can compare
this with a modern electron
micrograph.
And again, you can
see the similarities
between what Hooke
saw and what we
see in a modern scanning
electron microscope
at a similar magnification.
In the 1980s, atomic
force microscopes
were invented, which have
a resolution down to tens
of nanometers.
And today, there's transmission
electron microscopes,
which allow you to see
the atomic structure.
So for instance in
a crystal lattice,
you can see the individual
atoms and the regular crystal
structure.
Today, most experimental
studies of materials
include photographs of
the microscopic structure
of the material taken through
some sort of microscope.
And the remarkable thing is
that all of these studies
really trace back
to this book here
that we're looking at today--
to Robert Hooke's Micrographia.
[END PLAYBACK]
There you have it.
So I just thought
that was kind of cute.
You might enjoy that.
So that was that.
All right, let's
get out of there.
Stop.
So let's go back to the foams.
So I think last
time, we got as far
as talking about the linear
elastic behavior of foams
and modeling that.
But we didn't quite
get to looking
at the compressive
strength of the foam.
So I think we got
as far as comparing
the models with
these equations here,
and these plots of the data.
And what I wanted to
pick up with today
was looking at the
compressive strength.
And we'll look at the fracture
toughness as well in tension.
So we're going to
start with nonlinear
elasticity and the
elastic collapse stress.
So if we have an open-cell
foam, the derivation
for the elastic collapse
stress is really
pretty straightforward.
We say the elastic
collapse occurs
when the cell walls buckles.
So in this schematic here,
you can see the vertical cell
walls have buckled.
And so there's going to
be some Euler load that's
related to that buckling.
And that's just the usual
Euler load-- n squared, the n
constraint factor,
pi squared E. This
is going to be E of
the solid, I over l
squared-- the length
of the member.
And then the stress
that corresponds to that
is just going to be proportional
to that buckling load
over the area of the
cell, which is just
l squared, so just P
critical over l squared.
So that just goes as Es.
I is going to go
as t to the fourth,
because we have that
square sectioned member.
And now this is going
to be l squared.
And that's an l squared.
So that's l to the fourth.
And so if I combine
all of that together,
I can say that the elastic
buckling stress is going
to be some constant-- and
I think we're up to C4
now-- times the Young's
modulus of the solid times
the relative density
of the foam squared.
So that's our equation for
the elastic buckling stress.
And if you compare
this with data,
you can make an
estimate of what C4 is.
And we find that
C4 is about 0.05.
And you can also
say that 0.05 really
corresponds to the strain at
which the buckling occurs.
Because the Young's modulus
goes as the constants 1 times
Es times the relative
density squared.
So the strain's just going to
be the stress over the modulus.
So that does correspond
to the strain.
So that's saying that
buckling compressive stress
occurs at a strain of about 5%.
So that's open cells.
And then if we look
at closed cells,
if you recall when we
looked at the moduli
we looked at a couple
of extra terms.
One was associated with face
stretching for the modulus.
And the other was associated
with the compression
of the gas.
For the buckling, the
faces don't really
contribute that much, because
typically the faces are very
thin relative to the struts.
And because they're
so thin, they
buckle at a much lower load, and
they don't contribute too much.
So we're not going to worry
about that contribution.
So I'm just going to say that
the thickness of the face
is often small
compared to the edges.
And that really is from the
surface tension in processing
that draws material away from
the face and into the edges.
There can be some contribution
from the internal pressure.
So if the internal
pressure is greater
than atmospheric pressure,
then the cell walls
are pre-tensioned, and you'd
have to account for that.
So the buckling would have to
overcome that pressure as well.
So then you would have
the buckling stress
would just be what we
have up there-- C4 times
Es times the relative
density squared.
And then we just add on that
factor P0 minus P atmospheric.
The thing with the gas
which tends to affect more
than the buckling
stress, though,
is the post-collapse behavior.
So let me just show you
a couple of things here.
So here's some data for the
elastic collapse stress.
And you can see on
the y-axis, we've
got the stress normalized by the
Young's modulus of the solid.
And on the x-axis, we've
got the relative density.
And that solid line there--
sort of solid, dark line--
is that equation there, which
is the same as this one up here.
And you can see the data
lie fairly close to that.
But what's interesting is
if you look at the-- why
is this not working?
Maybe my batteries finally died.
If we look at the
post-collapse behavior,
you can see if these are
the stress-strain curves,
they're not flat here.
They have some rise to them.
And this is a closed-cell foam.
And you can imagine
as you're compressing
the closed-cell
foam, you're reducing
the volume of the cell.
And as you doing that, you're
increasing the pressure
inside the cell from the gas.
And you can calculate
what that is.
And I'll do that in a second.
And if you subtract off that
gas pressure contribution,
that works out to
this line here.
Then these lines will
be more flat, like this.
And we already really
pretty much worked
out that gas contribution.
So I'll just say for the
post-collapse behavior,
the stress rises due
to the gas compression.
And that's as long as
the faces don't rupture.
So if you have an
elastomeric foam,
typically they don't rupture.
And what we had
worked out before
was that that
pressure-- we called
it P prime-- it was P0
minus P atmospheric-- that
was equal to P0 times
the amount of strain,
epsilon, times 1 minus 2
times the Poisson's ratio
divided by 1 minus
epsilon times 1 minus 2 nu
minus the relative density.
And once you get to
the buckling stress,
then the Poisson's
ratio becomes 0.
So if you take a foam-- so I
brought a little foam in so you
can play around with this one--
so if you take a foam like this
and you compress it, once
you've buckled it like this,
it's not getting
any wider this way.
And part of the reason
for that is you've
got all these pores in here.
And the cells just
collapse into the pores.
They don't really need
to move out sideways.
So you can smush that
yourself, and try
to convince yourself that the
Poisson's ratio is just 0.
Yes, Matt.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I guess
I want to measure [INAUDIBLE]
the gas contribution?
LORNA GIBSON: Yes, so
there is a strain rate
effect with these things.
But I wasn't going to
get into that here.
If you look in the book,
it's described in the book.
So I think there's two things.
One is that the solid itself
can have a rate dependency.
And then there could
be something connected.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, I mean, I'm
not going to go into that here.
But one could look at that.
So let me just write
down one more thing here,
because if we let nu be
0, then this thing here
becomes simpler.
So we could say the
stress post collapse
as a function of strain would
be our buckling stress and then
plus this factor here.
So that curve on the
bottom over here--
if this is the stress-strain
curve-- this little
dashed line here-- that's
the gas contribution.
And that is this term here.
So you can kind of see how
the shape of the curves
reflects that gas contribution.
And when you
subtract it out, you
get pretty much a horizontal
plateau over here.
Are we happy?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
LORNA GIBSON: This is
for the closed cell.
Because the closed
cell are the ones
that are going to
have the gas pressure.
If it's open cells, the gas
can just move out of the cells.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, sorry,
that was to show you
that the Poisson's ratio was 0.
And that's true
for both of them.
So then we can look at the
plastic collapse stress.
Say we had a metal foam.
And we do a calculation
a little bit
like the one we did for
the honeycombs, too.
So we say the failure occurs
when the applied moment equals
the plastic moment.
And the applied
moment is proportional
to the applied stress
times the length cubed.
So I'm going to call that
applied stress-- our strength
sigma star plastic
times the length cubed.
So if you think of, say, the
little schematic up here,
the force is going to
go with stress times
the length squared.
And the moment's going to
force times the length.
So it's the stress
times the length cubed.
And then the plastic moment
goes as the yield strength
times the thickness cubed.
And then if I just
combine those,
I get that the plastic
collapse stress in compression
is another constant-- I'm going
to call it C5-- times the yield
strength times the relative
density to the 3/2 power.
And if we look at data,
we find that the constant
is about equal to 0.3.
And if I go to the
next slide, here's
a plot of the yield strength or
the plastic collapse strength
of the foam divided by the
yield strength of the solid,
plotted against the
relative density.
And that dark, bold line
is this equation here.
And you can see the data lie
pretty well on that line.
There's one data set that's
a little bit above the line.
But you can see the slope
of that data set is still
about 3/2.
OK, and the same as
in the honeycombs,
we could say that we
can get elastic collapse
before the plastic collapse
if we were at a low density.
You can get the same
thing in the foams.
And you calculate out what the
critical relative density is
for that the same kind of way.
So we can say we can get
elastic collapse precedes
the plastic collapse
if the elastic buckling
stress is less than the
plastic collapse stress.
So all we do is make those
two things equal to figure out
the critical relative
density where
you get the transition
from one to the other.
So the relative density has to
be less than 36 times the yield
strength of the solid
over the Young's modulus
of the solid squared in order
to get buckling before yielding.
And let's see, where
can I put that?
So for rigid
polymers, that ratio
of the strength of the solid
over the modulus of the solid
is about one over 30.
And so the critical relative
density for the transition
is about 0.04.
So you'd have to have a
pretty low-density foam,
but it's possible.
And for metals, that
ratio is about 1/1,000.
And then the critical transition
density is less than 10
to the minus 5.
So essentially, it never
happens for the metal foams.
And then for the
closed-cell foams,
we could include the
terms for face stretching
and for the gas.
But in practice, the faces don't
really contribute very much.
And typically for foams
like say metal foams
or a rigid polymer that had a
yield point, the faces rupture.
And then if the faces
rupture, then you
don't get the gas
compression term, either.
So I'll just write
the full thing down.
But typically, you
don't need to use it.
So the first term would
be from the edges bending.
And the second term would be
from the faces stretching.
And this would be from the gas.
But in practice, the first
term is really the only one
that is significant.
So for closed-cell
foam, this equation
works pretty well,
too-- the same one
as for the open-cell foams.
OK, so if we had, say, a
ceramic foam that was brittle,
there'd be a brittle
crushing strength.
And then we get failure
when the applied moment
M is equal to the
fracture moment Mf.
And this works very similar
to the plastic yield strength.
So we find the
applied moment goes
as the global stress
times the length cubed.
And the fracture moment goes
into the cell wall strength
times the cell wall
thickness cubed.
So the brittle
crushing strength goes
as another constant-- let's
call it C6-- times the wall
strength times the relative
density to the 3/2 again.
And C6 is about equal to 0.2.
And typically, ceramic
foams have open cells.
So I'm just going to leave it at
the open-celled formula there.
So there's one last thing
for the compressive behavior,
and that's the
densification strain.
And we just have an
empirical relationship
for the densification strain.
So if you compress the foam and
you get to very large strains,
then the cell walls
start to touch,
and the stress starts
to rise steeply.
And there's some strain
at which that occurs.
And we call that the
densification strain.
And in the limit, the
modulus at that point
would go to the
modulus of the solid.
If you could completely
squeeze all the pores out,
the stiffness of that would go
to the modulus of the solid.
And you might expect that that
densification strain is just 1
minus the relative
density, but it actually
occurs at a slightly
smaller strain.
So in a large compressive
stress, or strain,
I guess we could say,
cell walls touch,
and we start to get
this densification.
So the modulus in
the limit would
go to the modulus of the solid.
And you might expect
that the densification
strain was just equal to 1
minus the relative density.
But it occurs at a little
bit less than that.
So empirically, we find that
it's just 1 minus 1.4 times
the relative density.
And then I have this
plot here, which
is really just fitting a line
to that data for densification
strain.
So those equations describe
the compressive stress
or the compressive
behavior of the foam.
So we've got the moduli, we've
got the three compressive
strengths, and we've got
the densification strain.
So what we're going to do
later on in the course is
we'll use those
models to look at how
we can use foams and
things like sandwich panels
and looking at
energy absorption.
And we'll also look at
these equations in terms
of some biomedical materials--
looking at trabecular bone,
and looking at tissue
engineering scaffolds.
So there's one last property
I wanted to go over,
and that's the
fracture toughness.
So if we were pulling
the foam in tension,
and we had a crack
in the foam, we'd
want to know what the
fracture toughness would
be for a brittle foam.
And this follows the
same sort of argument
as we had for the honeycomb.
So all of these
equations really are just
following the same
kinds of arguments.
But you can kind of see
how having the honeycomb
calculations makes it
easier to do the foam ones.
So we'll do the fracture
toughness calculation,
and then I want to talk a little
bit about material selection
and selection charts for foams.
So that's less equation-y.
OK, and we're just going
to look at open cells here.
So imagine we have a
crack of length 2a.
And we have some
remote stress applied,
so remote tensile stress, so
I'm going to call that sigma
infinity-- the far-away stress.
And then we have a local
stress on the cell walls.
I'm going to call
that signal local.
So I have a little
schematic that kind of
shows what we're doing.
So we're pulling on it.
There's some crack.
The crack length is large
compared to the cell size.
And we want to know what
the fracture toughness is.
So we can say from fracture
mechanics the local stress is
going to be equal to
some constant times
the faraway stress times
the square root of pi a
over the square root of 2 pi r.
And that's at a distance r
from the head of the crack tip.
And if we look at our
little schematic here,
we could say it's hard to say
exactly where the crack tip is,
but it would be
somewhere in here.
And we'd say this
next unbroken cell
wall is a distance r
ahead of the crack tip.
And that r is going
to be related to l.
It's going to be
some function of l.
So I can say the next unbroken
wall ahead of the crack tip
at some distance r is
going to be related to l.
And that's subject
to a force, which
is going to be the local
stress times l squared.
So that force is going to go as
local stress times l squared.
And the local stress-- I can
substitute this thing here
in-- that's going
to be proportional
to the faraway stress.
And I'm going to
get rid of the pi's.
substitute for r.
I'm going to put in l.
So it's going to be proportional
to the faraway stress
times the root of a over l
and times l squared there.
And then we're
going to say, again,
the edges are going to fail
when the applied moment equals
the fracture moment.
And the fracture
moment is going to go
as the modulus of rupture of
the cell walls times t cubed.
And the applied moment is
going to go as f times l.
And I've got f from
up there, so that
goes as the faraway
stress, sigma infinite,
times the root of a over l.
And now I've got l
cubed, because there's
an l squared there and
there's an l down here.
And then if I just
equate those, then this
is going to go as sigma fs
times t cubed, like that.
So then I can say
the fracture strength
is equal to my faraway stress.
That's going to go as my
modulus of rupture times
the root of l for a
times t over l cubed.
And then my fracture
toughness is
going to be this tensile
stress times the root of pi a.
So there's going to be some
other constant here, which
I'm going to call that C8.
We've got the modulus
of rupture of the solid.
I've got the square
root of l, and I'm
going to multiply it by pi
so it's like other fraction
mechanics kinds of equations.
And then we multiply that
times the relative density
to the 3/2 power.
And here, if we look at data,
we find that that constant
is about equal to 0.65.
And here's another
one of these plots.
So here I've normalized the
fracture toughness of the foams
by the modulus of
rupture of the cell
walls times the root of pi l.
So I've taken the cell
size into account here,
and I've plotted against
the relative density.
And that equation
there is the same
as this equation I've
got down on the board.
And this is the only
one of the properties
that we've looked at that
depends on the cell size.
There's a cell size
dependence here.
All right, so I think that's
all the modeling of the foams.
Are we good?
I gave you a lot of equations.
We're good?
All right.
So I want to talk about
how we might design foams
to improve their properties.
And then I want
to talk about how
we might select foams
for certain applications
and look at selection charts.
So when we've been talking
about the foams, especially
the open-cell foams,
we've been saying
their deformation is largely
by bending of the cell edges.
And if we could do
something to increase
the stiffness of the edges
or the strength of the edges,
then that would increase the
overall properties of the foam.
And there's a couple of ways
to think about doing that.
So the foam
properties-- if the foam
is controlled by
bending of the edges,
and the edges have
some flexural rigidity,
EI, if we could increase
that EI of the edges,
we would increase the
properties of the foam.
And one way to do that is
by making the edges hollow.
So if we had hollow
edges, and you had a tube,
then that would increase the EI.
And we can work out how much
it's going to increase them.
And I have a little example
here of-- a natural example
of hollow foam struts.
So this is a grass.
I don't know what
kind of grass it is.
I just saw this grass.
And we picked some
different grasses,
and we took some SEM pictures.
And it has a really kind of
common structure for grasses.
It's very common for
grass stems to have
sort of a solid outer part and
then a foam-like inner part.
It's so common that
botanists have a name for it.
They call it the
core-rind structure.
And if you take
one of these grass
stems, and you look at the sort
of foamy bit in the middle,
and you do a SEM
picture of that,
you can see that the little
cell walls are actually
little hollow tubes.
So one of these things--
it's a little hollow tube.
So what I wanted
to do is work out
how much the modulus
of the foam would
increase if you could
make all the edges
into little hollow tubes.
So we're going to
start by saying
the foam behavior is
dominated by cell bending,
so edge bending.
And the foam properties can
be increased by increasing
the EI of the cell wall.
So there's a couple of
ways we could do that.
So the first one is
looking at hollow walls.
So imagine I have a
thin-walled tube-- just
a circular, thin-walled tube.
There's my little wall there.
It has some radius little
r, and a wall thickness t.
And then imagine I have
the same amount of mass,
but now I have a solid
circular section.
And I'm going to say the
radius of that is big R.
So for our thin-walled
tube, the moment of inertia
is pi r cubed times the
thickness, t, if it's thin.
And for our solid
circular section,
I is going to be pi big
R to the 4th over 4.
And if I say I want to set
this up so that the masses are
equal, then the areas
of the cross-sections
have to be equal-- say it's
from the same material.
So the masses are
going to be equal
if pi R squared is
equal to 2 pi r t.
So I'm going to
solve here for R.
So the pi's are
going to cancel out.
So the masses are equal if R is
equal to the square root of 2
times r times t.
And then what we're
going to do is
see how the big is
the moment of inertia
of the tube relative
to the solid.
And the tube is pi
little r cubed t.
And the solid was pi R
to the 4th, divided by 4.
And I'm going to
get rid of the R
here, and get rid
of the pi's there.
So R to the 4th is going
to be 4r squared t squared.
So the 4s are going to go.
And this boils down to r over t.
So if I had a thin-walled
tube, the moment of inertia
is going to be r over t bigger
than if I had the same mass
in a solid circular section.
So you can see for
the little plant
here, by making a
thin-walled tube,
you're increasing the
stiffness of the foam
with the same
amount of material.
That's the idea.
And you can do a similar kind of
analysis for other properties.
So that's if we
have hollow tubes.
So another option is we
could have cell walls that
are sandwich structures.
So imagine if the
cell walls themselves
were little, tiny
sandwich structures.
So when you have a
sandwich beam, what
you have is too
stiff, strong faces
that are separated by
some sort of porous core,
like a honeycomb or
a foam or balsa wood.
And the idea with the
sandwich structure--
if I draw a little sketch of
the sandwich, here's my faces.
So imagine those are solid.
So they might be
aluminum sheets,
or they might be fiber
reinforced composites.
And then we have some
sort of cellular thing
here as the core.
And the idea is, that's
analogous to an I-beam.
So in the sandwich
beam, we have two,
stiff, strong faces separated
by a lightweight core.
So the core is typically
a honeycomb, or a foam,
or balsa wood.
And the idea is, you
increase the moment
of inertia of the cross-section
with little increase in weight.
And if you think of
an I-beam, an I-beam
has a large moment of inertia,
because you're separating
the flanges by the web.
And the sandwich beam
works in the same way.
You're separating the
faces by the core.
But the core doesn't
weigh very much,
because it's a cellular thing.
So the faces of the sandwich are
like the flanges in the I-beam.
And then the core
is like the web.
So the idea is to make something
called a micro-sandwich foam.
So what you want to do is make
the cell walls into sandwiches.
And one way to do that is
to disperse a large volume
fraction of thin-walled
spheres into the foam.
And you have to get the
geometry right to make it work.
So let me draw a little kind
of sketch here of how it works.
So here's our
thin-walled spheres.
And then you're going to
distribute those in a foam.
Here's another sphere over here.
The spheres are not perfect.
Let's say there's
another one in here.
And then the idea is this stuff
in here would be the foam.
So these guys are
hollow spheres.
And say the spheres
have a diameter D.
And say they have a wall
thickness here of t.
And say that the separation
of the spheres I'm
going to call c.
You can see that there.
And then the cell size of
the foam I'm going to call e.
So there's a bunch of parameters
you have to kind of play with
to get this to work.
So you have to have thin-walled
spheres so the faces are thin.
The sandwich panels work
best when the faces are thin.
So you need the thickness of the
sphere to be much less than D.
You need the faces to be
stiff relative to the foam.
So you need the modulus
of the sphere material
to be greater than the
modulus of the foam.
And you need the volume
fraction of the spheres
to be relatively high to
get the spheres close enough
together for this to work.
So you want that
volume fraction to be
something like 50% to 60%.
And for the foam, you
need to have the foam cell
size less than the separation
between the spheres.
You need to have a number
of-- you can't just
have one pore in here.
That's not really like a foam.
It won't behave like
a foam as a continuum.
So you need to have a number
of different cell sizes
in between each sphere.
And so you need the
cell size of the foam
to be a lot less than the
separation of the spheres
there, c.
But if you can
control this geometry,
you can get the sandwich effect.
And you can get improved
properties by doing that.
So there's ways
you can play around
with the structure of the foams
to improve their properties.
So that was one thing
I wanted to say.
Another way to
improve the properties
of a foam-like
material is to use
one of those lattice materials.
So we've been talking
about ways to improve
the bending stiffness.
But if you could get
rid of the bending
altogether and have axial
deformation in the cell walls,
that would be much stiffer.
And you can get
axial deformation
by having those 3D
truss kind of materials.
So I have a picture of this.
There we go, so there's one
of those 3D truss materials.
So another alternative is to
sort of get rid of the bending
altogether, and to try to
make a truss-type material.
So there's various
ways to make these.
I think that we talked about
a few of them earlier on.
And you can analyze them
as truss-type structures.
And I can just
run through a sort
of little dimensional
argument to get the modulus.
So the modulus is going to go
as the stress over the strain.
The stress is going to go as
a force over a length squared.
The strain's going to go
as a deformation over l.
So this is just like what
we had before for the foams.
But in this case,
the deformation
is going to go with
the force times
the length over the area of
the cross-section divided
by Es, because we're pulling
it or pushing it axially.
So that goes as Fl
over t squared Es.
And if I just put that
back in the equation
here for the modulus, I get
that we've got F over l.
And I've got delta here,
so that's F l t squared Es.
And you just get
the modulus goes
as the modulus of the solid
times t over l squared.
And that goes as the
modulus of the solid times
the relative density.
So for the open-celled
foams, the modulus
went as the relative
density squared.
So if it was 10% solid,
the modulus would be 0.01.
And this is saying if it's
10% solid, the modulus is 0.1.
So it's much bigger.
So this is all sort
of well and good.
The only difficulty is that
when you look at the modulus,
you can do reasonably well.
But when you look at the
strength, some of the members
are going to be
inevitably in compression.
When you have these
truss materials,
some members are going
to be in tension.
Some members are going
to be in compression.
And the compression
members tend to buckle.
And once the compression
members buckle,
then you're back to the same
kind of strength relationship
that you have for the foam.
So that's one of the
difficulties of this.
So let me say that the
strength-- so if the strength
was controlled by
uni-axial yield,
it would go linearly
with relative density.
But if it goes with buckling,
it goes as the square.
So I'll just say the
compression members can buckle.
And say you had a metal lattice.
Then there's some interaction
between the plastic behavior
and the buckling.
And you use what's called
the tangent modulus instead
of just the Young's modulus.
And the tangent
modulus is lower.
And there's also what's
called knock-down factors that
can be large, too.
So the knock-down
factor can be like 50%.
So the measured strength
can be half of what
you thought it was going to be.
This should be a
squared over here.
Sorry.
So even though the stiffness
of these 3D trusses
can be quite good, the strength
often isn't quite as good
as one might hope.
So that's one of the
issues with them.
All right.
So do you see the
idea, though, with all
these different
micro structures,
is that you can control
the structure in a way
to try to increase
the bending stiffness
or get rid of the
bending stiffness
and increase the
axial stiffness?
So there's things you can
do to play around with that.
And I wanted to talk a bit
today about material selection
charts for foams.
So when we talked about woods,
we started talking about this.
Remember, I derived a
little performance index.
We said if we had
a material and we
wanted to have a
given stiffness,
and we wanted to
minimize the mass,
we had that performance index
that was E to the 1/2 over rho.
And we had a chart of
modulus versus density.
And we saw that wood
was really good.
You can do that for other
sorts of properties, not just
modulus.
So you can make-- depending on
what the mechanical requirement
is, you can work out
different performance indices.
So I want to go into that
in a little bit more detail.
So the question is,
how do we select
the best material for some
mechanical requirement?
So in the wood section, we
looked at the minimum mass
of a beam of a given stiffness.
And we saw that the performance
index was E to the 1/2
over rho.
So let me do another one
of these little examples,
and then I'll show
you some more of them.
So another example would
be what material-- minimize
the mass of a beam of a given
strength or a given failure
load.
So we'll call the
failure load Pf.
And we can see the
maximum stress in the beam
is going to be the moment in
the beam times the distance
from the neutral
axis y, and divided
by the moment of inertia.
So here, M is the maximum
moment in the beam.
And y is the maximum distance
from the neutral axis.
And I is the moment of inertia.
And I'm going to say
i goes as t to the 4.
And I'm going to define a
failure stress of the material
sigma f.
So sigma max is going
to go as my failure
load times the length.
That would be the moment.
The distance from the neutral
axis is going to go as t.
And the moment of inertia is
going to go as t to the 4th.
And that's going to be the
failure strength there.
So I can solve this for t.
And then I'm going to write
the mass in terms of t,
and put that in there.
So here t goes as Pf
l divided by sigma f.
And that's going to
be to the 1/3 power.
I guess I can scoot over here.
Then we can say that the mass
M goes as the density of times
t squared times l.
So the mass M is going to go
as rho times l times t squared.
So that whole thing
goes to the 2/3 power.
So if we look at the
material properties,
the mass goes as the density
times the failure stress
raised to the 2/3 power.
So if we want to
minimize the mass,
we want to minimize rho
over sigma f to the 2/3,
or we want to maximize
sigma F to the 2/3 over rho.
So that's the performance
index for that case.
So we can obtain these
performance indices
for different loading
configurations
and different
mechanical requirements.
And I don't want to go
through a whole lot of them,
but I'm going to put
this up with the notes.
So this is from Mike Ashby's
book on Material Selection
in Mechanical Design.
And this is a whole series
of these performance indices
for different
situations, for things
loaded in torsion, for
columns and buckling,
for panels and bending.
So these ones are
all for stiffness.
And they all involve a modulus
raised to some power divided
by a density.
So a tie in tension, c over
rho, the beam in bending
is E to the 1/2 over rho.
A plate in bending
is E to 1/3 over rho.
So you don't need
to memorize those.
But you can see you can derive
these for different situations.
And here's another one for
strength-limited design.
So the shaft is, depending on
what the specifications are,
it's the strength raised
to the 2/3 power over rho.
The beam loaded in bending--
the top one there-- sigma f
to the 2/3 over rho.
That's what we just did.
So there's all these different
kind of performance indices.
So depending on what
your situation is,
you would pick one
of these indices.
And then what you can do is
use these material selection
charts, which plot one
property against another
on log-log scales.
And because all of these
performance indices
involve a power,
they always end up
being a straight line
on your log-log plot.
And here this one,
I think, is the same
as what I showed
you for the wood.
This one's the modulus here
plotted against density.
So foams are down here.
And other engineering
materials are over here.
And these guidelines here
are the different performance
indices.
So this one's E over rho.
This one's E to
the 1/2 over rho.
the 1/3 over rho.
And for this case here,
as you move the lines up
to the top left-hand
corner, E is getting bigger.
Rho is getting smaller.
And so the actual value
of the performance index
is getting bigger.
So you can use this
to select a material.
So we've made these
charts for foams as well.
So here's a couple
of charts for foams.
And I think what I'm going
to do is just go through them
quickly.
And there aren't
really that many notes,
so I'll just put the
notes on the website.
And you can come and
write all the notes down.
And then we can
finish this today.
So this one here is the
Young's modulus versus density.
And these are all sorts
of different foams.
So the low modulus ones
tend to be flexible.
The higher modulus ones
tend to be more rigid.
And you could use this to
select foams, if you wanted.
You can also see what
the range of values is.
So the values of
the modulus here
goes from a little
less than a 100--
because this is two
orders of magnitude here,
I think, each one of these--
down to about 10 to the minus 4
or a little less than that.
So there's a huge range.
There's almost a range
of a factor of a million
in those moduli.
And the same with
the strengths here.
The strengths go from
10 to the minus 3
mega-pascals up to about
maybe 30 mega-pascals,
something like that.
And you can see for the
modulus and the strength,
things like the
metal foams are good.
The balsa's good.
Here's the balsa up here.
Metal foam's up there.
So you can kind of see
the range of properties
that you could get.
And then you could also--
need a drink, hang on.
You can also plot the
specific property.
So here's the
compressive strength
divided by the density plotted
against the Young's modulus
divided by the density.
And here you want to
be up at this end.
So you would have a high
strength and a high stiffness.
So the balsa and the metal
foams are good up here.
This next plot-- this is
the compressive stress
at 25% strain.
And this is the
densification strain.
And if you think of having
your stress-strain curve
looks like this,
something like that,
so you could say
that's a strain of 0.25
and that's the stress
that corresponds to that.
So that stress times the
densification strain,
which is out here
someplace, is an estimate
of the energy underneath
the stress-strain curve.
So you can think of this
right-hand plot here--
those dashed lines-- these lines
like this and this and this--
each one of those corresponds
to how much energy you
would absorb under the
stress-strain curve.
So points that lie
on here would have
an energy of 0.001
megajoules per cubic meter.
And over here, we're at
10 joules per cubic meter.
So again, the balsa and the
metal foams are good over here.
So you can use these plots
to try to identify foams
for particular applications.
And I think there's
a couple more.
It doesn't have to be
mechanical properties.
Here is thermal conductivity
versus compressive strength.
So you can imagine if you
wanted some insulation,
you wanted to have a certain
thermal conductivity value,
you probably also need at
least some minimal compressive
strength.
You could also have something
like a maximum service
temperature, that
maybe the foam is going
to melt at some temperature.
You can't go beyond that.
So there's some property there.
And I think there's
one more here.
You can look at things
like the density
in terms of the
buoyancy of a foam,
if you have some
buoyancy application.
And you can look at cell
size on this one here.
And cell size can be
important for things
like filtration and catalysis.
So the amount of surface area
goes as 1 over the cell size--
the surface area
per unit volume.
And so the cell size can be
important for those sorts
of applications.
So the idea is, you can make
these material selection
charts for foam.
And you can put data on there.
And you can compare foams.
And you can use these
performance indices.
So I'm going to
leave it at that.
There is a little
bit more notes.
But I'll just put
them on the website,
and you can get them from there.
So I think we're good for today.